[Music playing]
I'm Joe Penny
I am vice president of product engineering at Robinhood
Robinhood is a sturdy provider of free stock trading
All other stock trading services charge between $ 5 and $ 10
We offer this service for free
Today there are more than one million users to implement Robinhood
We were able to grow with a very small team
Android users love Robinhood
The user base has more than doubled
Robinhood applied on 4.6 stars
This is the highest rated stock trading broker in the Play Store
I'm Dan Hill
I'm an Android developer at Robinhood
We're two people on the Android team
We are proud of our ability to continue and work
Very quickly
Speed ​​and stability are available in Android Studios
This allows us to continue for longer
And away from administrative matters
That is, the tool's quality scale is in the fact that it is invisible
They are uncomplicated
It exists only
And on demand
One of the things I prefer about Android Studios
The shortcuts are available
There is a really wonderful shortcut
An abbreviation was prepared to search for any abbreviation
It will be displayed in conjunction with shortcuts on the keyboard
Or you can use it to learn about
Various shortcuts.
The new emulator is fast.
You can speed up hardware and use the GPU
In your device in order to speed it up
I like to brag about moving pictures
I feel happy when I swipe
To the top, seeing the deal disappear metaphorically
It is a strategic way to interact with stocks
These powerful tools provide
Our very small team can make a big impact
While developing Android products
We're always moving between files
We learn configuration files and different Java classes
Android Studio also provides a satisfactory response
To keep pace with the speed we want